[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about
whatever we want we got sherry back
i'm back baby jericho you gotta keep me
out i knocked on the door
every weekend that's nice i've been
trying to book you like every weekend
but you're too famous no i hit them with
the hudas sometimes
i'm like dude it's an instagram you can
see my picture what do you mean who did
it i call you brother
i call you brother that means a lot that
goes on how do you say it go go
you say go go right that's brother no no
no no just brother yeah the english word
brother she says
you guys don't share the the taiwanese
that's next level
babe i'm chinese babe i've been calling
[ __ ]
did i just out out of us joe has so many
romances dude
this guy every guest man every guest
i've been doing it i've been calling
strangers babe
where are we on that but we're not
strangers that's cool though that's cool
can i cover it up
i'm sweating is it more endearing though
you think people are like they open up
to you because you say that
i don't know what's what's the line
because sometimes like if a guy does it
you know what i mean i'm like ew
what yeah that's weird like little sis
calling no someone babe
looks like everyone's you know what i
love bro where are you dude
i'm on fart house i'm on pornhub hey
what's up step sister what's up
we move from brother to baby what if you
call someone cousin logan
i call people i've been calling people
cousin i'm not a [ __ ] so i don't do that
what's up cousin
right right i know that about you when i
was when i was in high school i would
call my friends like
mikho and mika because it was like
something that i just picked up from
being in mexico right and then um so
then when i came back i called a friend
like mikko in front of his girlfriend
and i didn't realize that
that was bad or does that kind of
belittle him or no no it's kind of like
a
like like a pet name like almost or not
but like flirty
flirty or like motherly like kind of
like yeah like more like i want to be
mother
like what do you have over my boyfriend
yeah yeah yeah
response or is it emasculating like that
no honestly
it's just like oh i'm sorry since when
did you two have nicknames type of thing
right
yeah well it came off more like i guess
for her like i was
hitting on him like flirting but i
didn't know that that happened in that
moment so then later on because we work
together me and this guy
and he started treating me like [ __ ] and
he started being so mean to me and i was
like
wait what happened like you bad mijo
then late like literally years later i
find out that it was because
i called him miko and his girlfriend got
so upset with him
and they got in a big old fight over it
and i didn't even [ __ ] know
that's crazy i will say that's the
biggest reason why i call guy's brother
why just so i don't have any beef with
their lovers so it's not a good thing
you call me brother yeah it's only
because i don't [ __ ]
i want you to get jealous default name
dude you know we're talking in the dms
i just want to make things clear that i
have a crush on geo not you
do leave me voice memos sometimes i do i
do cause sometimes i'm like it's too
much
it's too much i'd be leaving voice memos
where are we on that because voice
messages like
i would just hit you with one out of
nowhere sometimes i like them because
you can explain way more context you
know like you don't have to be perfect
like grammatically versatile yeah first
when you're texting you're like
what's the right way of wording this and
by the time you word it right it
took the feeling out of what you're
trying to say like that's true it's much
better to cut someone out on both
voice memos and to type it out and you
can get it out of your system
because it could come off friendly but
you're really trying to come off like i
wanted
i want them to hurt right you the
feeling i want them to press that play
button
and like cry yeah yeah yeah full
monologue
and they might not be good readers so
when they read it they might be like
[ __ ] wait what because [ __ ] is really
gonna [ __ ] yeah that's where they're
gonna mess up on the reading
no i actually find myself re-recording a
million times though because i'm cause
like that didn't capture my thoughts did
you listen to it
i'm like it's like an old answering
machine no i'm so narcissistic i'm like
is this more for you for me
it's just like my my voice over at real
dude that's true
sometimes it's some voice because the
text is just way too long and then in
case you'll be with me and i'm like
listening to him like did i see that
right
yeah we're having a production meeting
on how well you performed
voice memo it's it's very important
that's me with emails
cause you know you gotta edit you gotta
clean it up and then when you send it
sometimes i get a response and i read my
old email and i go man that was a sick
email dude
it was supposed to be for efficiency
right i spent like an hour writing a
[ __ ] novel you know
that's what you do we're just we all we
care about is ourselves like we will
send the email and then go straight to
the set folder and read the email
immediately and then be like oh that was
good
you know what i've been liking i've been
liking the automatic replies that they
just
yeah like it's like all right or like no
i'll see you then i'm just like
i just clicked that one no i i don't
like it because i'm like [ __ ] that you
don't know me
don't assume what i'm gonna say yeah
because sometimes they do
and i'm like how did you know you know
me better than me is putting mudda
in your auto review
[Laughter]
man every time i see it i'm like
i get paranoid i look behind me i'm like
what the [ __ ] yeah how do you know
the following you know too much about me
yeah um well i was gonna ask
this to joe earlier just completely
change the subject
money or honey that's what we're just
talking about money or honey
because my mom used to always say no
money no honey right
and what does that mean it just means
you pay up if you wanna
yeah if you wanna you know gotta take a
ride baby
it's like an uber driver let's go yeah
that's it money helps increase your
chances of getting honey
no i believe okay not like you're buying
vaginas
obviously i mean you're more attractive
to other people but it gives you a
chance to have more fun and freedom and
all that where you can
have time to meet someone special yeah
yeah like if you're somebody with a cool
job you're like oh cool
wow excellent you're way more intrigued
right but if not
but then like you'll have certain people
where it's like oh because i have money
i get to treat people like [ __ ] because
no matter what i can just pay
around those people suck anyway though
yeah yeah they're always gonna say yeah
but but but your question is is it just
getting laid or
do you say honey like love what is it i
think maybe just getting laid
okay i can always make money
i can always make money but [ __ ] is
scarce for a man
yes deep because it's the opposite right
ladies can get dick anytime they want
i mean you would think really really
i'm popping i i think this is what it is
the dick away
that you want like like ditch will come
flying right but it's not the one that
you want
yeah a lot of guys will rip off their
dicks and just throw it out yeah it's
different it's not the one that they
want
yeah yeah and you're like dodging it
like matrix forgot you're doing the
[ __ ] matrix dodge no
it's like it's just a fruit ninja yeah
you know
and then you're on stage trying to do
comedy and people are throwing dicks
people throw eggs they don't throw
tomatoes anymore when you're bad they
throw their own dicks
but it is like a yeah but being a chick
is like having a pantry full of dicks
it's just you open it and you're like i
don't like any of these and some of them
expired
you know in the pantry it's like the
fridge you know you open it and you like
i'm hungry but nah and then you open it
again hoping that something new will
come out yeah but for dudes it's an
empty pantry empty fridge
all the time and you have to go can i
borrow your fridge no money no honey
what does that mean like hey yo can you
hook me up with some here for her with
your friends
okay is your cousin single so you borrow
other people's oh god i got a guy not
not not pantry items that belong to
others yeah that's what i thought right
like wait i'm like i think every chick
has like a whole row of like just friend
zone dudes ready to jump on them right
and they could be busted they could be
whatever like a pantry full of dicks
guys it's like my pantry's empty you got
a pantry like what's happening
it's your girl you gotta go out shopping
full yeah go out
shopping yeah the clubs are packed with
dudes they're so [ __ ] thirsty
yeah right see that experiment with the
um
so they they you know guy went up and he
was like asking all these girls if they
would want to get laid or whatever and
then like it was like
100 no but then a girl went up and it
was like almost 100
yes from all the guys that were like
guys will [ __ ] anything and anyone
right that's true so i think that's why
for it's it's like
uh for girls they're taught you know you
got to get the money before you get the
honey right and then for like guys it's
like we want the honey because we
i don't know like even if i'm broke i
still want the honey honey is more
valuable than money
sometimes well think about it we're the
ones getting things put inside of
us you're just putting your [ __ ] inside
of someone else what a concept
it has to be it has to be a yin and yang
though because if we all just wanted to
[ __ ] each other all day
we would get no work done yeah exactly
right i mean we still do want to [ __ ]
each other all day but like
not as much not as much how often do you
all think about sex
all the time since the moment i wake up
till i go to sleep dang that's exciting
well
except when i'm here i'll be honest i
think i think about sex a lot
yeah no one here you don't want to [ __ ]
anyone here the stat
the staffer dudes is you think about sex
every seven seconds
that's the stats men or one is that true
for a man yes where'd you read that
we're hearing that too no it's like
every seven seconds regardless if
it's like oh this looks like a titty oh
what the hell it's just like cotton
okay i'm not horny trying to beat my
self off 24 7.
like i'm leaving the tv on in another
room it's constantly playing oh
deep sometimes you like pay attention oh
there it is that's a good analogy y'all
that's why when you're a kid like a lot
of the times like boys non-stop would be
like that's a boob oh that's a butt oh
that's a dick oh look at this dick
that's a dick
right yeah and that's why the guys when
they're bored the go-to thing is to jack
up
but it starts there because everything
is like you start
i think my mind i i do think about sex a
lot
every seven seconds i think every six
point five six point five
here's the thing though here's the thing
although i think about sex all the time
i don't think sex is high on my list
of priorities sure and also like
qualities and things
uh for a person yeah right i do think
men are so driven by sex that's how they
like
achieve things um i see that like i want
a [ __ ] nice car
so i could get girls it's the sigmund
freud right what is it the the
freudian the theory summit no that's if
you want to [ __ ] your mother
sick sick freedom royal
that guy he wanted to [ __ ] his mom the
tiger the tiger wants the [ __ ]
yeah everyone's mom um
i love that room full of [ __ ]
entertainers are they still doing that
are you yeah vegas no
they didn't die past one of them died
so who replaced them nobody so they're
just done they're not
wait are you ser he died from the tigers
like in the 90s or something
it's so old i think one of them died
from old age
or like from recently is the tiger still
alive
no i think they put them down really
yeah i think so
yeah low key though it's like come on
what do you expect you know
i i'm shook right now i miss a vegas
show i never saw the blue man group did
you oh they're good yeah
yeah yeah and they're still around wait
no no vegas shows
no no i've seen the britney spears one
have you seen oh
oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ] have you seen oh yeah
it's the one where everyone looks like
they're about to die every second
like they're [ __ ] dying yeah yeah
like diving into this
like water stage [ __ ] it's crazy i still
love the beatles one
oh that was a good one yeah i really
like it how is britney
amazing i mean you know it's ready were
you sad though a little bit because it's
like
not her you know what she yeah it's like
you know about her
now i know okay okay after the
documentary but this was like two years
ago when i went to see her but is the
production crazy is it like you know
there's some
vegas shows where it's like okay they
really toned it down and one's
like celine dion i heard is the [ __ ]
[ __ ] every single time yeah i think they
have the titanic on stage right wow yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
do you guys remember the music video
wait there's a music video it's all
the titanic dog is it not it's all
shipyard and [ __ ]
yeah wait the whole movie is for music
okay you know what i
always think about like if they were to
do a reboot of titanic
who would play it yeah let's talk about
it no no i actually want them to do
another titanic movie but
focus on different characters on the
same ship
that's a tv show that's a tv show
titanic burst
titanic versus like lost and at the end
of the episode they always crash
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then and then you see the next story
yeah
yeah oh black mirror [ __ ] like what if
what if what if everyone on the titanic
this reboot they're bisexual by tannic
yeah yeah and then they just find out
they're in purgatory the whole time so
it's a big orgy oh there was another
movie that was like that
poseidon or something well i haven't
seen it no no there was this one movie
where
they were actually like it was a ghost
ship and they kept they didn't realize
that they were dead but like they were
parts of the caribbean
yeah oh spoiler
to be honest i don't think i've seen a
single one of those it is my favorite
ride or one of my favorite rides at
disneyland though are you talking about
pirates like
no not pirates yeah pirates no yeah but
that's not totally i know
but it's finding it's the same concept
yeah wait ghosts in a boat
yeah i think it was poseidon or
something oh wait isn't that the oh no
i'm thinking about pompeii that's the
volcano wait there's a pipe there's a
pirate movie with chao young fats a
pirate right is it that
that's the third pirates of the
caribbean oh he's in that one
yeah i'll watch that one chinese pirates
chinese vampires
oh the one that jumped like this one
a lot of powder you gotta introduce that
to american audience i've thought about
it wait
i love that as a kid i've literally
thought about it because there's
yeah how do you pronounce it in chinese
because in japanese uh they would dub it
and they call it kyonchi
i don't know you just challenged me on
camera i'm so sorry i don't know the
answer
but i thought you were authentic
shanghainese shanghainese
shag hi nick shanghainese
saying
but yeah they're scary very scary i've
never the only time i've ever seen that
was through your guys's skit
i i've never seen a joke scary as [ __ ] i
remember watching as a kid
but then later on when i uh but they're
comedies too
but then as a kid they're so scared
because like they just keep going
forward they're unstoppable
and then like someone will hide behind
the wall and you think they're safe and
then their arms
go through and you're like oh my god
but then you to get the paper and slap
their forehead with it and it freezes up
yeah and then they're like and they
freeze but they're still they still jump
it's still kind of wobbly right and then
all of a sudden like
wind blows and it goes
yeah wait really a piece of paper it's
like a it's like a um
like a omen or no what do you what do
you call it like an amulet like when
they ride
religious [ __ ] on a paper and then and
then like they protect
you know it's kind of like and then
that's the spell that's why we need to
have chinese graphics
like this this [ __ ] beard pulls one
of the [ __ ] scrolls out of his sleeve
the chinese buffy
that's why you always got to keep a
scroll nearby you just never know
what you can't have one maybe that's why
they have those sleeves because you can
put all kinds of
gigantic pockets when it comes to magic
man
when it comes to magic dude you guys
need the sleeves
all wizards wear sleeves look at that
circumference thank you
very good it's like that's a compliment
you said it's so nice to me is that a
kimono
it is kind of but then yeah show it off
honey
do a catwalk it's from japan it's like
authentics authentics and it has pockets
indigo dyed
yeah super durable i have one that's
denim i want one
yeah that's not denim you want to wear
it it looks
tough i like it yeah it looks really
tough it's like judo [ __ ]
oh yeah like do a choke on me do a choke
yes yeah use your martial arts you're
gonna like this yeah and then you go
behind and just go
ah wait is that death that is dead yeah
he's a trained killer maybe okay what's
up we were just talking about this why
do
guys just love like fighting each other
for no reason cuz you know what there's
nothing like it why do dogs [ __ ] lick
each other's balls this is it
because it's homoerotic because you
secretly want a bone
yeah no i don't know like we're all
literally on a bone we're all a little
homoerotic just a little bit secretly
want a bone
i never thought of that yeah that's all
i think about when someone's trying to
murder you you're just too hard
to watch like a boxing match i'm like
they're like they should kiss right now
this would be
the perfect moment for a kiss or mma
fight yeah they're just they get so
close
and they're like true dude there's a lot
of a lot of times that they get in
positions where i'm like they could
easily
yeah this is kamasutra like remember the
uh the cirque show we watched they were
doing kung fu and at the end they
started [ __ ] making out like crazy
wait it was searching and i knew the guy
that did that that was
cod he taught us how to do kung fu it's
kung fu phillip
oh that white guy really yeah that was
him oh yeah because i was like
that looks familiar no it wasn't [ __ ] it
was
it was humanity remember that kung fu
and zumanity
yeah there were two guys [ __ ] kung fu
and then i was like you know be funny
right now if they just like started
making out and they did
and then they started going at it dude
they heard you they heard you say that i
think that
and they're doing crowd work yeah they
were improving make up
yeah give me suggestions you went from
more to passionate love dude
it's just kind of funny that's what it's
about though one of my favorite scenes
of
comedy movie history was uh 21 jump
street
when uh jonah hill was it john out yeah
jonah hill and
homegirl like were fighting in there oh
yeah are you are you trying to kiss me
right now
no that actress is [ __ ] funny that my
fear and anything she's so
you know what i realized a movie needs
three funny moments
because walking away i remember nothing
except that moment
popping each other's [ __ ] that line
and my name is jeff yeah
those three days yeah and then in my
head that was a hilarious movie
but i only remember three things what
was that korean jesus queen jesus was
good too yeah that was good
yeah that korean jesus needs a spin-off
jesus
or no uh it could be a mash-up maybe
korean jesus is the captain of
he's like a side character and then he
saves everybody at the end he's like yo
i'm jesus
alternate ending to the reality yeah it
could be a different thing
we'll we'll we'll work shopping we'll
workshop it we're so close we're so
close we're on to something
have you watched gangs in new york the
cameron diaz and leonardo yeah cameron
diaz you know there's a scene when they
go into the chinese gambling den i want
to know about those guys that's a great
movie they didn't make that into a tv
show we should just go into all white
movies and find the like the one asian
scene and make that into a full movie
yeah yo we're gonna be so rich yeah get
the money
and the honey and the honey and then do
it again and then do it again repeat run
some repeats more money more honey
that's the way to win and then after
we're done we can go in the asian movies
and then find the white scenes and then
they don't blow those up
no those would just be little ig stories
a boomerang if anything there's enough
there's enough i mean you gotta make
more you know come on yeah
let's hold off on that
[Music]
you